les restaurants fermés des stations
d'essence fermées des communautés qui se
disent si quelqu'un le parti libéral au
village il pourra pas me qui leur sont
chers c'est pas la pandémie qui a créé
cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est pas
la piscine ni la poussière qui le crime
est ce que les prestations mises en
place pendant la pandémie sont la
principale cause de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
[Musique]
815 1000 postes sont vacants en ce
moment au canada et 880 milles personnes
reçoivent la prestation canadienne de
relance économique
mais ça ne veut pas dire que tous les
postes seraient comblés demain matin si
la pcr disparaissait l'arrimage n'est
jamais parfait entre les compétences des
chômeurs l'endroit où ils habitent et
les postes disponibles
oui les prestations peuvent encourager
certains à rester à la maison plutôt que
d'aller travailler
mais la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est un
problème qui existe depuis plusieurs
années déjà et au québec si le
vieillissement de la population qui le
facteur déterminant depuis dix ans près
de cinq cent mille personnes se sont
ajoutés au groupe des 65 ans et plus il
y en a seulement 20 milles qui ont joint
les rangs des 20 à 64 ans
bref beaucoup plus de gens partent à la
retraite comparativement à ceux qui
entrent sur le marché du travail
l'économie continue de croître alors que
le bassin de main-d'oeuvre se rétrécit
selon l'institut du québec ont compté
dans la province sept chômeurs par poste
vacant il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui on en
compte seulement 2 on peut mieux
utiliser notre système d'immigration
on peut aussi aider dans l'
éducation pour la formation aussi
l'immigration améliorer la formation en
fonction des besoins du marché du
travail sont en effet des pistes de
solution pour venir à bout de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre l'automatisation en est
une autre